hey everybody is Jessie and today we're
going to keep working on our react
project that we've been working on for
this is day 19 so I've just been working
on the video page so I have the the
proper embed codes now for all of these
videos and I noticed something when I
was doing this that I want to correct
something that I said earlier so I think
on Monday I had noticed something odd
about what the way the float X class was
being applied and I think I figured it
out and whatever I said about it on
Monday I don't think it was correct I
can't remember exactly what I said but
you know I just noticed it so I didn't
have time to go back and and watch the
video and see what I said but but check
this out so right now I have let me show
you so on this h2 at the top I have the
float X class on the container div but
then for these h3s oh yeah
for these age 3s I have float X right on
the h3
I think that I said that float X was not
being applied directly to the H tags if
I put it on there and that's not correct
I'm not I'm not exactly sure what I was
looking at on Monday when I thought that
but that's obviously not correct and
I'll show you I'll show you why
so let's take a look at this this h2 so
we can see the float X classes are
showing up and at first it looks like
all right none of them are there but
once you shrink that down it's obvious
that this got smaller so let me make it
bigger and smaller one more time
so definitely smaller I mean we can even
double check that I'll make this a bit
bigger for you all be able to see those
those more than a bit it's a lot bigger
I let's stir this up there we go all
right so we can check out the computed
styles and it will tell us exactly I
mean I I think I can tell just looking
at so that's about 28 pixels there
almost there
29 and we make it bigger now we're up to
40 right so it's definitely acting like
the flow text should act so if we check
sit still
that's odd so for whatever reason I'm
not sure why but for whatever reason it
just shows up in dev tools that has
crossed that and I I think I might have
mentioned that that's possible that was
the case before and then obviously
what's happening with these is it's
actually overriding the default H tag
styles so if I were to put flow text
directly on this H tag it would become
the same size as this so this h2 would
be the same size as the h3 so if you
want to keep the H styles but then
somehow still have it be responsive
which like I said from dev tools I can't
really see it maybe you all can see
something and I'm just missing it since
I'm trying to look at it now live but
kind of a I don't know just a small
difference but it it makes a big
difference when you when you view it you
know the h2 is definitely a lot bigger
if you put that on the container div so
for this page I'm gonna keep it as it is
now because I like the size for these H
threes I think the H tag is the correct
tag to use in this case these are
definitely headings but I like the size
that the that it's getting now from flow
text even when you shrink it down I like
that size but I don't like this size for
this age too
so we're gonna leave it like this the
only thing I may change at some point is
the font weight to make it the same as
this but just just wanted to add that
correction to what I had said earlier
and so that's out of the way let me say
hi to everybody I see some of you on the
latch
Sana's back awesome so I hope you had a
good time on on holiday and where was
your in Greece right so anyway that's
cool so for everyone watching later on
or if you can't see the live chat
susanna who was frequently in the live
chat hasn't been here for the last two
weeks because she was on vacation on
holiday so welcome back it's good to be
back
I do have the secondary stream going on
Instagram so if you're on Instagram you
can check me out the my username is in
the description to this video if you're
checking this out on the Instagram live
stream you can see the code for what I'm
working on on a free code camp YouTube
channel and that'll still be available
even afterwards as a recording on
YouTube and on Instagram the recording
will be available for 24 hours
afterwards alright so let's get started
I'm thinking today just to give you a
timeframe will code for about an hour
and then then we'll go to Question and
Answer we'll try to keep it under an
hour and a half for this session let's
see I don't think there's any other kind
of announcements or things to get out of
the way I did have some pool requests so
let me show you a little bit about
what's changed so everyone's up to speed
we have I think visibly I don't think
there's anything visibly that's happened
so we're just gonna check out the code
and the pool requests
yeah let me let me just bring the pull
request over to keep it straight in my
mind so we did three yeah I pulled in
three full requests this morning
so yeah it was this one
43 44 and 46 so we have a readme file
now that is not just the create react
app readme which is awesome so thanks
for that so let me show you so I want to
give credit I'm trying to infer there
there we go so Cathal thank you for
contributing so this is the first
contribution to this repository really
appreciate it
Thanks so I wanted to put put your
profile up there and give you proper
credit for that and so we also had pool
requests from Sebastian and one from
Patrick so Sebastian added react helmet
and I it can do more than what we're
using it for right now but what what
Sebastian added was the ability for us
to change the title tag for each page so
before it just said resource center no
matter what view Iran now it says
whatever the title of the page is and
then I think we have the - and then
resource center so you can check that
out of course on on github if you want
to see more of the code and then Patrick
refactored that generic card component
that we've been working on so you know
this has been this has been kind of cool
component because it's gone through a
lot of changes since we first had
and it just keeps getting better so
Patrick added debounce so brought that
in from lodash and we've seen that
before in our last project we use that
with our live search feature so we're
using that now for for our depth right
so our mouse mouse overs to get that car
give the car the hover effect
we're also I mentioned this on Monday
that it would be nice to have was to
open external links in a new tab so
we're checking here to see if the link
starts with the slash which means it
would be an internal link otherwise
we're going to treat it as an external
link and then in that case if it's
external we had target blank which will
open it in a new window if its internal
we leave that off so it'll just stay
within the same window so really good
that's good thinking to check link zero
so the first position of the link to
check for that slash that's that's
really cool kind of a nice like simple
way to do that so I really like that so
anyway thank you to everyone who
submitted pool requests and if I'm
missing something in your pool request I
apologize but I just tried to kind of
sum up what each one was about as
quickly as I could and now let's let's
move on so I just let me make sure that
I committed those last changes I think I
did yeah I did commit them but I don't
think I pushed them yet to get up so
just so you all can see everything that
is up to date as possible a wolf
alright awesome and I think the only
significant thing that I've done is I
updated a few packages a few NPM
packages so I was getting let me see
so I manually updated yarn because I had
a version that kept trying to do like
this auto update and it just wasn't
working so I looked it up and evidently
you have to manually update so the auto
update feature just hasn't been working
for a while so I did that and then I
started getting errors because I said it
couldn't find node SAS so I upgraded the
notes that's packaged and then it worked
not exactly sure what the problem was it
could be that somehow that package got
in this place delete it I don't really
know but if you're having some error
like that upgrade the node SAS package
and it should work also upgraded the
reacts let's see react scripts that's
what it's called so I can't even find
where it is react scripts here we go so
upgraded react scripts so one version up
so that version came out I think last
week sometime in the beginning of August
and I so decided to upgrade to that my
main reason other than just it's good to
be up-to-date my main reason was I'm
still I'm considering ejecting for the
the pull request that we had went over
on Monday so got a much better
explanation so check out that pull
request I believe it was 42 for I think
there's only one or two pull requests
that are still open right now so it's
one of those but it's the one that had a
lot of changes one of which being it
ejected create react app
in order to do some cool stuff with our
loading SAS so I do like that so in case
I go with that and I do eject I'd like
to have everything as up-to-date as
possible before I object the jack so
that was kind of in preparation for that
but there's since we've done so much in
the last few days there's a lot of merge
conflicts now so we'll see what kind see
how it goes all right so we need to
finish up with this this layout stuff so
this page is good so we're working on
posters I put in the correct links and
so this page is pretty much it's it's
finished it does look kind of bare
excuse me it's nice so this does look a
little bit better so I may put in those
font icons like I have in the current
version of this which if I can find it
I'll show you all yeah so the current
version has these font icons kind of
makes it a little bit less plain so we
may go with these because I mean ice if
I had started with this maybe it
wouldn't look so plain but since we're
comparing it it definitely could use
something so we may add those in at some
point but we've already gone over adding
in thawing icons in react with material
UI so not not really gonna do that right
now so I guess the next thing that we
can do is add let's see so we've gone
through home logos posters literature
okay so the only section that we've
really not put in what we need to is a
service request form section so it looks
like it's it's ready but at least
obviously we need to change these but in
the main the live version of this when
we click on the service request form it
shows us the Planning guide first so
that's what we're gonna that's what
we're gonna do at first I guess I think
it would be more user friendly to just
link to the planning guide here like
would like we're doing down here but my
my bosses wanted to show up before you
even get to this so I I did add this
skip to form in there so it makes it a
bit easier for users so I think we're
gonna stick with the way that my bosses
wanted it and then maybe bring up the
neck when we need about this I'll bring
up maybe skipping to that just so that
we don't have to make people you know go
through this every time so let's get
this on the page and I'd like to combine
some of this it's gonna be a bit more
scrolling but I think more scrolling is
better than more clicking let me know
what you think about that but to me it's
it just seems a bit easier to have
people scroll the only downside is it
will it will seem like there's more text
on the page because there will be so you
know if you have to click each each view
only as a small amount of text if I
combined that all into one I don't want
it to be overwhelming so if it does look
overwhelming then maybe we'll split it
up again but I'd like to see what it
would look like if it were all on the
same
all right so let's do that now I believe
I've created the page
let's see use planning guide okay so we
have the planning guide page
and we're basically just going to need a
card actually we talked about this
didn't we I think we talked about this
before that we may try to do this
without cards and I think we had some
mixed opinions about that as to whether
or not we should do it with or without
cards you know how that looked so I
think it looks nice like this but at
first I do I kind of want to see what it
looks like
without being in a card especially since
we're gonna put it all on the page it's
gonna be quite a lot it's that would be
a very long card so let's try it first
we can always wrap it in a card later on
that won't really be difficult if we
decide that we want that so for now we
have so we have our H make sure we're
not linking to this so let me see what
are we calling this planning guide the
links should be just planning guides so
let's go there so we can see what's
going on when we change things all right
yeah so it's just really basic
let's build out this page a bit more so
let's start with the container div oops
class name
container
and
we may want to
actually I was thinking that we might
want to pull in the vertical alignment
but this is going to be so big we won't
we really won't need it so I think we'll
be fine with the container div inside
that container we're gonna put a row
actually this is going to be if you're
kind of a beginner in in reactor
front-end development in general this
might not be a bad livestream for you
I know occasionally beginners ask me
will you know will I be able to follow
this and sometimes the answer is
probably no you know maybe if we're
working on some stuff with Express
sometimes that's a little bit more
difficult to follow if you're not used
to it but this is gonna be a lot of
basic you know layout so we are using
the materialized CSS grid system so
that's why we're doing this in this
specific way if you're familiar with
bootstrap then materialized CSS is
basically does the same thing as
bootstrap but with the material design
style
all right so we have this now and we're
gonna put that h1 here I think we have
been we've been doing h2s the let me do
an h2 for now I'm not super worried
about the H tags if I were making a site
that I really wanted to worry about SEO
search engine optimization I might give
more thought to the tags the header tags
and what was in them but this site does
not need to be SEO friendly it's an
internal site I actually would prefer if
it didn't show up in any search engines
so which is also why we're not worrying
about server-side rendering not now
search engines some search engines may
be able to render this and all right but
if we're pulling data from an API which
at this point we're not but it's not out
of the question at some point to do that
then basically your content would be
invisible to search engines because they
won't they won't wait around long enough
for the API call to come back and your
content to be rendered they'll just
think it's a blank page
if you do want to know about doing
server-side rendering to accommodate
search engines you could check out the
first project that we did where we used
next Jas to handle or server-side
rendering really alright we could I
don't want to see what the spacing is
like here and let's see do we have
actually we do have sub headers let me
um let me do a separate row then
all right so I'm I was thinking about
making this all you know just in one row
and one column but I think I'd actually
I'd like to keep it separate it may make
it easier later on to put things into
cards if we do end up putting them into
cars I may break the cards up by section
so that we don't have one big card and
if that's the case then I'll probably
probably want each card to be in its own
column class and on large screens we may
even separate it out depending on how
much content is in there and instead of
having every card be full page width we
may do two columns so that that's why I
was hesitating so much right there I was
just trying to think of what what I may
do later on so well actually you're not
gonna call that planning guide view
right now I have some instructions at
the top of that page so I'm gonna make
that the h2 and then our first section
is titled plan ahead so let's do that
and we want this to be an h3 with that
to be an h3 and now we're just gonna
have some paragraphs
I'm just copying pasting some content
that I have up on my other screen from
what I had just showed you a little
earlier
just one more paragraph after this one
and that will give us a good idea of
what this is gonna look like about how
much space is gonna take uh whoops
there we go all right let's check this
out okay
so right off the bat I know these these
header tags are all messed up in terms
of font size so what we need to do to
make this the same as the other pages is
apply our float X class and in the same
way that we've done on the other pages
I'm I'm considering using flow text here
as well
if we really want people to read this
then it should be a reasonable font size
and right now at least on my screen this
is not reasonable so I'm sure for you
all it's even worse the terms of font
size but I just think it would be
difficult for me to read this so I don't
want to make my users read that as well
and let's see okay it was 16 is that no
sorry I was looking at the wrong thing
where's the font size
that's odd I thought I had a maybe I
didn't I thought at some point I had
made the default font size 16 pixels but
maybe I didn't know maybe I just did it
from one page I'm not really sure all
right so let's try to add flow text in
here in a few places and if we make
we're not flow text here and I'm going
to add flow text flow text here let's
see if that gets applied to everything
alright awesome it did alright so you
can see that that definitely looks like
it'll be easier to read I'm not sure
about that line height though let me
know what you all think I'm sure line it
all right we're not it's not even
showing us lion height
I do want to see
some helpers are typography T I'd like
to see what the line height is for
material lives for flow text yeah that
looks like it's definitely a bigger line
height than what we have right now so
let's check that out line height line
height 1.5 and that's directly on the
HTML all right let's see about changing
the line height because otherwise it's
it's not gonna be nearly as readable and
let me just pop
let's see alright great let me meet him
make this a bit smaller so we can toggle
that line hi you just to see the
difference yes that's that's a huge
difference
all right that's what we were missing I
was I was messing with this a little bit
earlier trying to look at the line
heights and this was what I was was
going for what I was missing earlier
that makes a huge difference in
readability so we're gonna throw that
line height in there and I think I'm
gonna put this line height on flow text
it looked like in materialized at least
on their website they have this they
have some extra styles going on on their
website that aren't in the materialized
CSS so that line height was in those
styles so I'm not sure I'm not sure if
it's worthwhile to try to look through
materialized and find where they're
adding this line height because I right
now I know I want to use this on float X
but I'm not sure I want to use this
anywhere else so for now I'm just gonna
put it on anything that has that flow
text class to it so let's find our sass
file where we're using flow text which
should be responsive text and
yeah
well if you if you want to see what SATs
can do this is a really cool example of
sass doing crazy stuff that you can't do
normally in in CSS so check that out
that's that's on the repo and I didn't
do this this is from from materialize
but really cool stuff alright so now
that we have that in there should be
able to refresh and it should look the
same yep it does great actually I don't
I don't mind how this looks without
being inside of a card I think that's
way too much space between here so we'll
do something about that yeah but I don't
I don't mind it definitely looks plain
but we're not really we're not really
going for flashy we just want to get
information across the people one thing
that might be nice if we do end up going
making this section a lot longer is to
have some sort of scroll spy so let me
let me show you like materialise has I
don't know if I want to do it exactly
like this but you can see on the side
like as you scroll it lets you know
where you're at and then you can click
that to go right to the section you want
that might not be a bad idea to have if
this starts to get really long
but we'll see let me go I'm gonna go to
the live sex I haven't checked in in a
while I did set my Pomodoro timer but I
said it a bit late so I may have
actually been yeah it's already been 35
minutes since we started so let me go I
I know I asked you I asked you all some
things several times and I never checked
for an answer so I'm gonna check now
okay cool so Kevin said definitely like
more scrolling instead of more clicking
so alright so I had asked I had
mentioned that I think more scrolling is
better than more clicking so glad glad
that weren't agreement on that Kevin
okay John Hanson had an idea he said and
posted resources just put a single to
pixel or three pixel green line under
each heading length of the lines should
be with n cards left or right padding or
margins I said the icons icons look ok
so so not like in the icon yeah
actually thank you for that feedback do
you all do you like the icons at all or
did you say like forget the icons let me
go back to that page just briefly here
the poster resources so instead of icons
just put a single green line under each
heading
okay so we're just gonna have a line
under Hugh then okay I'm just trying to
visualize this right now
okay
I think about ouch what I think about it
maybe we try it out yet just there we go
okay okay Sebastian said for future
projects that you use create react app
check out react snapshot to make it more
SEO friendly or use something like
Gatsby cool good to know I've been doing
a lot with create react app lately next
J s was what I'd used previously for all
my projects but this project obviously
is being using create react app and my
projects for the Udacity react
nanodegree courses are all done with
create react app so lately I've been
working with that again used to it so
that's that's good to know that you know
it could be done it could be SEO
friendly even with create react tab okay
so Kevin said I didn't know the H tags
are meaningful for SEO could you explain
a little about that okay so let me give
the disclaimer that for SEO it's been
it's been about two years since I've
really considered myself knowledgable
about SEO so when I started being a
front-end developer full-time I quit
taking on clients for SEO related work
so I just wasn't interested in that
anymore it wasn't gonna help me with my
front-end skills and I didn't need the
money to take on clients like that so
having said that this knowledge may be
outdated but I think it's still it's
still true so your most important like
HTML elements for SEO number one is
going to be your title tag that's just
that's been my experience that if I want
to boost an SEO or change things the
single biggest thing I can do on the
page in the markup to change my ranking
for certain keywords is to change the
title tag at least that's that's how it
was you know two years ago between like
you know from five years ago to two
years ago I had a lot of success in
local SEO with just changing the title
tags now beyond that your h1 tag would
be the next most important things and
then your lower tag so in general what I
always recommended in what I what I used
was so every page definitely you want to
unique title tag and you want that title
tag to have some significance for the
keywords that you want to rank for but
not just the keyword it needs to
actually describe what's on the page as
well I don't want to be misleading with
that and then you wanna have one h1 on
the page and that should also be
descriptive it shouldn't be the same
thing as your title tag but it should be
accurate in terms of what the content on
the page is and then you can have
multiple other tags H tags beneath that
but it should make sense you should use
H tags for their intended purpose as
headers you shouldn't use them for just
to style things right if you just want
some font to be bigger that's that's not
the point and this is basic stuff right
so this is not like secret SEO knowledge
or anything this is just good practice
for for markup for HTML but I think it
also works with SEO and that it presents
the search engine with a clear structure
of your page and what it's about as long
as you do it accurately so the like I
said the H tag should accurately
represent the content that there the
header for and I think it you are more
likely than
to be indexed accurately based on your
content so anyway that's why that's my
SEO moment today so like I said haven't
I have not researched SEO very much at
all in the last two years so it's
possible that it could have changed but
those are just some some general rules
definitely do your title tags give some
thought to what key key words you'd like
to rank for have one h1 and then use
your H tags appropriately as headings
not for style purposes does that make
sense
and if anyone else is more into SEO
right now and you have anything to add
to that or if I was wrong about
something please let me know
okay so Damien says I'm a day or two
behind so not sure if you've covered
this yet but I was trying to fix the
scrolling such that the resource / side
nav would scroll down as you go down the
page I tried to use fixed CSS but
resources the resource would hover over
cars actually I've never tried this I
just so
[Music]
so Damien said I wanted to get the
effect that the resource menu would be
available as user Scrolls down so I'm
just to be clear about what we're
talking about do you mean you want this
to be able to scroll down with as we
scroll at first I thought you meant this
but I I don't know if you can but I
can't even scroll at all while this is
open so I guess it makes more sense that
you'd want this so let me know if that's
what you were talking about Damien and
yeah that might not be a bad idea to
implement something like that so we'll
have to check out material UI I would
imagine that they probably have
something built in for this but I
haven't I haven't tried to do it so but
I could see at first I didn't think
about it because all our pages
originally didn't really require very
much scrolling but if we're gonna have
pages like this which will have a decent
amount of scrolling then it does it
would make sense to allow the user to be
able to you know get to this side nav
even if they've scrolled you know down
the page alright
okay so I'm gonna go back to the code
and let's check out so Sebastian just
let me know about the stepper and
material UI so let's check that out
because if we can put that in the page
now that might be kind of the most
exciting thing that we can do on this
page so it'd be cool to get that done
you know while we're doing this so I'm
actually let me move this on the screen
so you all can see since I just spent
about I don't know eight minutes maybe
maybe even 10 minutes going through some
of the questions in the live chat I'm
not gonna do the break right now I'm
just gonna restart this you know now and
then we're gonna do one more 25-minute
session and when this is done that'll
put us a little bit over that hour that
I wanted to spend coding and since I
spent a lot of time earlier going over
some of the pull requests and the
changes then it'll be okay if we go over
that hour and then after that I'll go
back to the live chat and answer
questions so it's fine
stepper whoops stepper
okay all right yeah this
so definitely the vertical stepper makes
a lot of sense and yeah instead of you
know clicking obviously we would want
this to happen on scroll which it looks
like yeah okay so it looks like you can
control that
okay so we can control based on the step
index where you're at which one gets
highlighted so if we would just track
the scrolling yeah if we track the
scrolling on the page and then change
our state based on the scroll position
then that should work and you know we'll
we definitely want to change you know
how this the default styling of this
which is just fine
cool thanks Sebastian I yeah I think
this will definitely work and yeah this
is pretty it's not exactly what we
wanted but it has enough of what we want
that I think it's worth trying to adapt
this all right well let's get a few more
sections on the page so that we actually
can have enough enough space to scroll
to really try this out and then let's
try to add it in and probably what I'll
do is we'll try to add it in you know
kind of as is just to see if we can get
it to work and then we'll worry about
styling it the way we want it okay so
let me add in I got logged out of so
this my friends this can get Lugg love
me out so there's you don't really have
a lot of time in there before you get
logged up but I have
I do have all the code available and
maybe I should just copy and paste that
because that's on github so I don't have
to worry about getting logged out so
let's do that and that'll be nicer I
won't need to manually make all the
paragraph tags I'll just copy them over
so yeah let's go with so the current
order is after the plan ahead then we
have a list of all the different types
of things that we can do all our
services but I think we want it I'm
gonna try to change that order I don't
see anything yeah I don't see anything
in the text that that's in there that
would a user would expect to see a list
right after that of services so I think
we can safely change the order of this
so right now I have this
I will need to change the age tags
but it should work I should be able to
just paste this in and have it work so
we definitely don't want these to be age
ones
area
I'm going to make these h threes and
we can change this too
this will be a link
to
and then we'll need to import slowed up
in there
I believe I grabbed an extra div that we
do not need there we go we need to
import link if yeah so we're not using
that already so have it here I thought I
had it
how am i linking to these oh you know
what now I remember we switched it to
generic card so we wouldn't have to
bring in links oh here it is
okay now we'll see how that looks
great make sure that works yep that
works okay
it gives us a bit more bit more space
all right now we also have a larger
section that are all the services
I think that that may make sense as a
separate section
let me just I'm just gonna put it in
down below so you all can see it we can
figure out whether we want it to be in a
separate section I mean it would be
beneficial if users did see that because
they may not really know it all the
things that we do so it might be
important that they see at first and
they don't have to click to get to it
and this would be cool because this this
will have some markup that is somewhat
less common I know I had never used this
markup before until I did this project
so we have all these these deals and DTS
right so this is actually I wonder what
the default styles will be okay not bad
not bad
so if we could if you see each so each
DL right has DT which is like the title
and then your d DS which is your content
right so this is if you're gonna have
like a dictionary style listing this is
the proper markup to do that so you'll
have you know your word and then your
definition
all right so that's yet not really sure
what I want to do with that yet see what
a tag were using okay so you're actually
using a shoe it's good it doesn't really
look that good to have the header be an
entire sentence
I may switch this
yeah let's switch this
I think this
we'll look a bit better there we go okay
so if services and that's a bit of an
introduction and then we have this okay
all right not bad now let's try to put
that that scroll well we'll work on
making it via Scrolls by style list so
let's see if we can fit it let me think
how we gonna fit this in
I guess this will end up being a fixed
position so it's really gonna exist
outside the normal flow of our layout so
it won't it won't really matter where we
put this I'll probably put the mark up
for it above all of this and then we'll
give it a fixed position and it will
stay with the user the entire time yeah
that makes that makes the most sense for
this so let's grab let's grab some of
this markup lose the line this one
I would see if we're getting anything
from interior UI we're not
we'll grab everything from now and
probably won't need to keep it all
though
I guess this may actually be better as a
separate component at some point right
now let's just we'll just take all this
and put it in our component just to see
if it works
actually it was this the one I'm gonna
see if I'm getting the right one okay
now I want a needle on with the granular
control right yeah
there we go
this will bring in the styles too since
it's it's not gonna like it if I don't
bring in the style
okay
now
style should I feel it'll do
yeah we're definitely gonna need to
change those to fit with our page but
for now we'll just grab everything
and put it all inside
inside this div doesn't make sense to
put it above the title but I'm gonna
give us some space okay let's let's see
if we've done this correctly
oh that was I'm excited that was a lot
of copy and pasting and I to get it all
in the right spot click a step to get
started next next great
okay so everything's working we have
more than we need and we need to style
it differently and for some reason I
grab the horizontal I guess instead of
the vertical I'm not sure how I didn't
notice that but we did need the granular
control where's our vertical looks like
we can just switch to orientation
vertical and let's see if that'll work
for us we're so stepper
great all right so we have a vertical
orientation now which is awesome let's
move this over this is gonna look really
bad at first while we test it but the
only styling that I want to do at this
point is just to make it fixed so that
as I scroll I can still see what's going
on
there we go position:fixed great I don't
want it on that side I relive it on this
side so
right
whoa
all right so that's why it's giving us
there we go
gonna get rid of that that width and we
want to add that great and that actually
yeah that's that's not a bad spot later
on it might not be a bad idea to have it
down just you know a little bit more but
I thought it was gonna overlap this text
but it doesn't it's too close so it
doesn't look great but for right now
that's good that'll just let us see
what's going on so let's grab this style
here and you should be able to change it
yep go change it here we can just
replace this with
that and we need to also add that
position I forgot to copy that over some
fixed oops and we need commas because
this is an object great whoops
what did I do nope I did not put that in
quotation marks
okay great
all right now we need some sort of
scroll
let's save material UI
all right so let me let me ask this see
if any of you know before I before I
start searching not that I'm against
searching but it's just boring if I'm
searching while I'm live-streaming
so is there something built in the
material UI that I can use that will
track scrolling if not is there
something for react the track scrolling
that I could use and if there's not
something specific for react I just need
some sort of plug-in that is vanilla
JavaScript don't want jQuery that tracks
scrolling if none of those if we if we
don't have any of those things then
we'll just have to do it from scratch
which is cool but we're not gonna have
time to finish that today so I'll check
I'm gonna give it a minute or so and
then I'll check the live stream or I'm
sorry the live chat see if you all know
anything about that
also I I wouldn't worry too much about
the scroll tracking working with
touchscreens so there's going to be some
use cases where people may have a large
screen that is also a touch screen but
those will be small but the use case in
which we'll have a mobile screen where
when you touch I'm not as worried about
because this will just be hidden on
those screens we will not have enough
space to put this in so for now I'm just
worried about normal scrolling that's
not touch based
okay so it looks like Sebastian says it
doesn't look like there's any anything
built-in materiai
all right so my search is on the other
screen some of the top searches have
used jQuery but it looks like I found
one that's vanilla JavaScript
it's a it's a pretty old answer though
it's from seven years ago so it might
work but maybe I don't want to find one
that's that's different
okay so then says what do you mean by
track scrolling basically I just want to
know the users scroll position on the
page so that once let's say when they're
at the top section this part will be
highlighted but then once they get here
then that second section will be
highlighted then the third section right
then will have a fourth so I want to
know when the user gets to a certain
point in the page at that point I want
to change the state which will then
change which one of these is highlighted
so these will all correspond to a
section on the page okay does that make
sense
actually there's a I don't need this but
there's a react Kurt react cursor
position NPM package that sounds really
cool it'll give you coordinates for
where the cursor is so fYI that's that
sounds really cool
I'm finding finding stuff about how to
do this with react native
okay look I have found some code that it
looks like people use this for react and
it has worked so then in the live chat
says a manual window dot on scroll will
be the handiest okay that's that looks
like
it looks like some of the stuff that I'm
seeing on my other screen with the the
searches so that's probably what we'll
go with so we're not gonna do it in this
stream but I think this will be kind of
cool to do on a live stream so I'm gonna
save it I'm not gonna work on it and
we'll work on it tomorrow
what's tomorrow Thursday okay yeah I'm
pretty sure that I don't have anything
going on tomorrow afternoon so it should
be same time we'll have time to do this
I'm not gonna work on it if one of you
really really wants to work on it and
submit a pull request for it that's cool
too I'm open to that in which case we
would just take the beginning of
tomorrow stream and go over how that was
done either way I definitely want to
show on the live stream how we do this
because I imagine this is I'm well for
sure I'm not the only person trying to
do something like this in react and it
wouldn't be useful just for this it
would be useful for any type of
animations that you want to happen as
the user Scrolls and I'm sure there's
you know 100 other things that would be
useful for as well so I'll work on other
things there's definitely a lot of a lot
left to do a lot of small style things
and so I'll work on that
now the coding portion of this is going
to be done so if you were just sticking
around for the code you're not
interested in the question and answer
session thanks for watching and you
could go do whatever you need to do now
otherwise if you have any questions
please put them in the live chat right
now I'm going to try to get through all
your questions and answer them as best
as I can and not just me everyone in the
live chat is very knowledgeable and
helpful and provide some great answers
too so if you think I'm a noob and you
don't really want my opinion then it's
still worth it to put a question alive
because there are other people in this
lab chat that are far from being noobs
and are very knowledgeable if you don't
want to put something in the live chat
for whatever reason you can direct
message me on Twitter or message me on
any other social media platform that you
like to use or you could put it in the
comments to this video and I'll get to
it when I can probably the most reliable
way to get in touch with me is a direct
message on Twitter if for whatever
reason I just tend to get to those
messages faster than I do to like let's
say comments comments on the video are
actually a little bit hard to keep track
of for me because there's a lot of
videos now so I trying to go through and
find which videos have the comments a
little bit difficult alright so let me
scroll back up and
on Shaddai answer any questions it
doesn't look like there's a lot so this
may not may not be a very long
question-and-answer session
okay awesome so it looks like in with
the text the font size it looks like you
all think that the larger font size with
the increased line height is definitely
better easier to read so I'm glad glad
you all agree with me on that I've
actually had some pushback from people
who I'm building websites for here at
the university that they're they don't
really like the larger font size mainly
because then they can't fit as much text
on a page it looks huge my response is
usually well maybe there just shouldn't
be as much text who's gonna read all
that text that then also hey it's a heck
of a lot easier to read it when it's
when it's a larger font size
okay so Kevin had an idea about the
poster resources so we had talked about
posters so but first I talked about
putting a big icon at the top here like
I have on the live version but it seems
like that's we're not gonna go with that
at least I had some feedback from some
of you saying that that would not look
good which is fun I'm definitely open to
a change we had John said well what
about putting a line under here and now
Kevin says what about the Green Line and
then also an icon on the left left like
a chrome notification card so we would
have a much smaller icon over here which
of course would push this over and then
the line so yeah we could try that as
well yeah it wouldn't be a big deal to
try both ways and see how they look so
maybe we'll do that if I have time maybe
I'll try to do that before tomorrow
streams so that we can compare and see
which one looks better
okay and earlier Damien had an idea in a
question about how to make it work to
make this stay fixed at the top so I
asked him for clarification and in fact
it was so basically once that would
sometimes it's called a sticky nav or
fixed navigation and where we would
scroll down to can't do in this page
we'd scroll down and it would still stay
there so yeah so we've done that on
previous projects well we kind of had a
version of a sticky and at one previous
project right we had one that kind of
went sticky as we scroll but yeah I
definitely think that's a good idea so
we'll try to implement that as well so
thank you for that Damien
so Chaz Chad says hello I'm a new hey
Chad don't worry about it I definitely
consider myself somewhat of a noob too
in many areas so you're in the right
place
hmm okay Damien says I've been having
some issues when trying to push to
github with everything up-to-date is
there a way to resolve this I did try
googling and just end up pulling your
work he said any tips on resolving this
error
let's see yeah Damian so not sure so
then had some advice for that to make
sure that you add the changes and commit
the changes first and then do your get
push so I'm not sure
yes adamian not sure if that advice
would work or if you're already doing
that or not so yeah let me know if you
want to message me on Twitter or
something so we can talk about it and
get some more information and I'd be
happy to help you
okay XANA actually is is not a fan of
the sticking of it says it takes up
space maybe go with an arrow to the top
instead
alright let's let me think about that it
does take up space it's not a very tall
header though wouldn't take up that much
space maybe we'll have to think more
about it I
I mean I'm also fine with having that
that little arrow to the top would
definitely have well especially if we're
going to do a scroll tracker then we
could have it so that once you get to a
certain point of scrolling then the
arrow appears what what if we did this
alright how about this idea
what if we had it so that as you scroll
it looks like this but as soon as you
scroll up a little bit it appears no
matter where you're at so a lot of I
think apps do this
so as you're scrolling down the top bar
just disappears but if you just scroll
up a little bit it'll it'll come back
again so I that may be the best of both
worlds so that it's not blocked if you
don't want it to block your view right
it won't block your view but then if you
want to see it all you have to do is
just scroll up a bit hopefully that
makes sense did I do this I do think I
did this for something I guess I guess I
could show you an example in case it's
not clear to anyone just gotta remember
what project that did this on
I let me see if it's this project
no not that one
okay all right so I've done it here so
I'm gonna bring this over so this is a
project that I did sometime last year
and you can see I mean this is a
transparent nav so it's not really that
permanent anyway but it goes away and
now as we scroll down you see goes away
when we scroll up it just appears right
so something like that might be cool to
have
all right so hopefully that was a decent
illustration of what I was what I was
talking about
okay cool so about the salami let me
bring this over since I just had this
question if I can find this
sorry I know I'm I'm not making sense
right now but let me show you what I'm
talking
all right so Matt was able to catch the
live stream right now so he's in the lot
the live stream in the live chat so
about this pull request so if you want
to check it out pull request 41 if you
want to check it out this is what we're
talking about so you can see this is the
explanation which is excellent you know
very detailed so anyway Matt's in the
chat right now and he's saying about the
pull request is setting state like you
know just using state equals and then an
object the newer way and let me see if I
can this should be me up here so setting
state like this as opposed to using the
constructor like this he's asking is
that the newer way so essentially like
part part of this pull request was
changing from this to this assuming that
this is the preferred way and it's a
better way and that this was not the
best way to do it but it may be the case
that this is just a newer way to do it
and is acceptable
so that's that's the question
all right so
all right so Ben says you can do it like
that in the constructor for the initial
state and then set state for all changes
yeah so I think what we were
okay so Ben I think Ben is actually
saying do it in the constructor as well
you stay
yeah so basically yeah let me explain so
I could probably bring up and show you
the difference in context here so for
instance in generic card component we
are using the constructor right and
we're doing this state and we're adding
things in here
but in I know we're doing it differently
in one of these components so let me see
we were we were doing it differently
there we go so for instance here in
logos Jas I'm setting state initially
just like this right as opposed to doing
it like this with within the constructor
okay and Matt said that he he actually
talked to someone who is a developer for
a for a large startup company and said
that he's been doing it this way like
we're doing here for a long time so not
sure that there's any difference okay so
been saying I think both work this is uh
this is a good question like
who
so I think
maybe I need to do a bit more research
on this so right now in in this project
most of the time we're doing things like
this in fact this this may be the only
time when we're doing it like this I'm
not exactly sure about that but it seems
like this is the way we've been doing it
and it works but this also works right
I've been on this page it works as far
as I know there's no errors so let's see
those
okay yeah so no errors even as we change
the state there's still no errors so in
terms of what works right we know that
it works but I guess my
so basically but my thing is that at
this point is assuming that they both
work and that these are both in use and
you know in react projects that are out
there so you know so evidently there's a
developer at a large startup that's
doing it like this so assuming that
these are both in use and they both work
which we know they work is there any
difference and then would that
difference simply be a performance
difference or is there something bigger
that um that we're missing on this
actually you definitely would like to
know about this so if you're watching
the recording it would be nice maybe if
in the comments let me know which way
you you handles this I do you use one or
the other or a combination sometimes you
use one or the other or what's your
reasoning behind it so definitely I mean
this is definitely beyond my current
knowledge of react I think I'm pretty
sure that in the react course that I'm
taking right now this was the way so the
one way we're doing an engineer card
Jass is is the way that they've shown
how to do that but like I said just not
sure what the difference is
okay
okay Pat Fewell says it's es7 new to a
lot of people okay so it's see we have
quite a discussion going on now in in
the live chat about this issue so all
right so at this point I think I'm I'm
to the bottom of the you know I'm to the
end of the the live chat so I'm I'm
gonna wrap this up but if you want to
continue this discussion in a live chat
sort of way check out the slack channel
[Music]
so let me show you all the slack channel
so FCC live stream so FCC - live -
stream slack calm so we have this slack
channel so you can continue the
discussion if you want to I'm definitely
interested in this and I'm gonna try
five time I'm gonna try to research it a
bit more as well maybe look at some
other projects and see how they're doing
it so
okay so thank you so much for watching
and for all your help and the live chat
I really appreciate all your your
opinions on you know on everything that
we're doing and today especially it was
more about the look of things which is
definitely it's super helpful just to
get a second opinion a second and
sometimes third and fourth and fifth set
of eyes on this you know right away that
immediate feedback really ends up making
it look you know so much nicer so yes I
think that's it for day sorry the
discussion is still going on in the live
chat so I was just reading the last few
a few comments there but I will be back
tomorrow okay matt said to let him know
about the pool request yeah I've
definitely yes oh I've downloaded that
that pool request as a separate branch
and I've been trying to test it out the
thing I had today is that so I tried to
merge the changes that were in master
into that pool request into that branch
and I didn't get through them all before
I so I just a lot of things that have
been updated so I couldn't get through
it all and kind of properly test it but
I I definitely want to so I'm gonna try
to give that give that a shot when I can
cuz hopefully sooner rather than later
because the more changes I make it's
just gonna make it harder to merge
everything okay so I'll be back tomorrow
sorry I keep trying to say goodbye and
not doing a good job of it but I will be
back tomorrow and same time 2 p.m.
Eastern Time and we'll work on that
scroll the scroll spy and that oops I'm
back too far there we go so we're gonna
work on this tomorrow until then have a
great day and I'll see y'all tomorrow